Vanessa Bryant is seeking monetary
damages in her wrongful death lawsuit
following the tragic loss of her husband
Kobe Bryant and their daughter Gianna
according to a new case summary filed by
Vanessa on Monday she is asking for
substantial compensation from Island
Express helicopters and claims the
family lost hundreds of millions of
dollars in future earnings from Kobe's
death
now the 38 year old mom of three is
seeking compensation from the company
which owned and operated the helicopter
that crashed claiming the lives of her
husband their 13 year old daughter and
seven others On January 26 and from the
estate of the pilot Aras Obion who also
died in the accident - echo X ray you're
still too low leveled well for off by
following at this time Vanessa
first filed the wrongful death lawsuit
back in March in the original 72 page
lawsuit obtained by ET Kobe's Widow
cited several areas where the pilot may
have been negligent the lawsuit also
alleges that Island Express helicopters
had advanced knowledge of the unfitness
of the pilot due to a previous violation
in 2015 the new case summary which was
filed by Vanessa on Monday indicates
that the lawsuit is currently stalled
pending the release of the National
Transportation Safety Board accident
report which has yet to be generated as
the crash is still under investigation
attorneys for the bayan's estates have
requested a transfer to a county outside
of Los Angeles citing an impartial jury
cannot be impaneled in Los Angeles
Superior Court back in March a company
spokesperson for Island express
helicopters responded to Vanessa's
lawsuit telling ET quote this was a
tragic accident we will have no comment
on the pending litigation as for Vanessa
she's remained strong by spending time
with her daughters and close friends
when ET caught up with her pal Walla
Anthony in April she applauded her for
her strength I tell her every day she's
the strongest woman I know
and I'm really really proud of just how
she's handling everything and just want
to continue to be there you know as much
as I can for her as a friend she's just
an amazing and amazing human being just
just amazing